It has been a very long night and day here
at the David Pakman show, one bleeding into
the next. You have no idea what we've been
dealing with since about 9:00 PM last night
until very late this morning. I'm sort of
in disbelief that this is going on. But I
am going to report to you today, uh, that
our, uh, coverage of last night's democratic
presidential debate on CBS was shut down midstream
jeopardizing our entire Twitch account and
the revenue that comes with it.
But the details here are what is sickening
and this is way bigger than the David Pakman
show. The stream that we were running yesterday
of the debate with our commentary and your
participation was cut either by high priced
consultants hired by CV CBS to shut down independent
media or by some kind of right wing troll
group posing as representatives of CBS. Now
this may sound confusing and it is, and I'm
going to try to explain it to you as clearly
as I can because so much of this information
is still developing. We're in the middle of
an investigation, we're engaging lawyers and
as you can imagine, this is not what I want
to be dealing with in the middle of one of
the most important elections in our history.
But this is how they win by making me have
to deal with this stuff. So sit down and get
a load of this one.
As many of you know, we do our debate on Twitch
where we've built a nice following of close
to 30,000 viewers. It's not 810,000 like we
have on YouTube, but we have a growing and
steady base of close to 30,000 followers on
Twitch yesterday during the debate about halfway
through our stream, which at the time had
close to 6,000 live viewers. A nice debate
for us, we had a lot of great audience participation.
It was a great alternative to the disastrous
moderation that was being provided by CBS.
Our stream was shut down and I was notified
that we had received a copyright strike. These
copyright strikes do not expire on Twitch
and that means that we are now permanently
one strike away from losing our Twitch account
forever. The whole point of building up Twitch
for the last eight months was that the streaming
on YouTube had become too risky because YouTube
is already in the pocket of so many of the
large media companies and they can shut us
down anytime at the press of a button.
So we started building up an audience on Twitch
and it became a nice source of revenue for
us. So I get a message and it says you've
received a copyright take down for your stream
of the CBS debate. Now my initial assumption
was of course CBS started striking people
doing commentary on the debate that they were
broadcasting. But upon further inspection
it looks like my stream, Sam Cedar's stream
the surf stream, try heck Sue's stream and
a whole bunch of others. They were taken down
not by CBS but by a shadowy organization called
Praxsis political legal. If I look at the
email I received, it says it was actually
practices political legal who took down my
stream on CBS his behalf. Now, this is already
very odd because a lot of the companies as
large as CBS, they have an internal legal
and copyright team that handles this stuff.
They don't hire someone else, but when they
do, they hire someone that you would be able
to sort of find information about and that's
where this gets even weirder. Praxis, political
legal lists a contact email in the copyright
take down that they sent me. That email is
legal at Praxis, Paul pet practice pol.com
so I immediately emailed that address to see
what's going on and to explain what we were
doing and that, you know, we want to have
this strike removed. The email address does
not exist. Practice political legal lists
and email address where when you email them
you get a bounce back that says address not
found. So now it's starting to get really
weird Praxis, political legal files, a copyright
take down for CBS. Their contact email does
not even exist. So then I said, well, let's
find the website for practice. Political legal.
When you go to their website, they claim to
provide political consulting and legal services,
but they provide almost no information whatsoever
about who they are and in fact they don't
even have their own website. They use one
of these cheap single page placeholder websites
by a company called card with two RS, C, a.
R. R. D. it's like a company that has a website
that is company name.blogspot.com very weird.
We aren't able to find any real evidence that
this company exists, at least under this name.
So we have two possibilities here and they're
both really bad possibility. Number one is
sometimes these hatchet job, political consultancies,
they deliberately maintain almost no internet
presence specifically because they focus on
doing things that they don't necessarily want
to be known for like shutting down left-wing
streamers commenting on a debate. So it's
possible that it's a real company that CBS
really did hire them and that's sick.
That if that's what's going on, the other
possibility is because CBS has not in the
past shut down independent media streams of
debates. And because companies the size of
CBS again often handle copyright stuff internally,
not by hiring out. The other possibility is
that this company is not really representing
CBS, that they have fraudulent. Lee claimed
to Twitch to be representatives of CBS in
order to shut down streams like mine and so
many others on Twitch. So either way, this
is a crisis because first of all, no corporations
should have a monopoly on the platform that
people can view a debate that is being used
to decide who is going to represent the democratic
party in the general election and who is going
to be president ultimately if they are going
to defeat Donald Trump. I've said it before,
it's disgusting that one can monopolize something
that is in the public interest or supposed
to be anyway when the moderation is good.
Uh, like a debate. It's disgusting. But if
it turns out that this is a fraudulent group
claiming to represent CBS and they're just
lying about who they are, then Twitch has
a real problem here. The contact email for
this practice, political doesn't even exist.
How did Twitch even set them up as a, uh,
an arbiter of copyright takes down take downs.
What they do in order to shut streams like
ours down if indeed they are, fakes is falsely
represent themselves to Twitch as agents of
CBS. That's an issue. If that's the case that
Twitch needs to deal with and YouTube as well
needs to deal with immediately. Now in the
meantime we've had to obtain legal representation
because our Twitch account now is at risk.
One more bogus claim and our entire Twitch
account is shut down for forever. Okay, so
I hate that this is what's going on, but I
think we have to fight it with legal services
and that's not cheap.
We could do the minimum, which is like I just
don't do, I need more debate streams and they
win. Maybe we have to do that. I don't want
to do that. Okay, a B. But if we get one more
strike on Twitch, we're done. Like that's
it. Our account has done for good or we can
get really involved fight it. I want to do
that. Get a lawyer, try to get these strikes
removed and figure out who is behind this
company. So grab a membership. If this bothers
you, if you believe that this is what we need
to be fighting against at a time that is so
crucial for our democracy, where we are trying
to decide who is going to fight against Donald
Trump, disinformation, propaganda, all of
this stuff is happening. Grab a membership@joinpacman.com.
Okay. Um, I, I just, I can't believe that
I spent the better part of the overnight dealing
with this, but it's where we are and we've
got to fight it. So, uh, the coupon code 2020,
now I don't care if you discount your membership
or not, we just w anything helps. It does
going pacman.com you can sign up in under
a minute.
We're also on Patriot patrion.com/david Pakman
show speaking to lawyers again this afternoon.
I will update you sometime later this week.